uh i watched the dune movie is that a
hot topic
i mean people are talking about it
it's it's a movie yeah it's something i
saw right okay how was it [ __ ]
amazing really i don't i don't like i
genuinely don't understand like normally
right
online okay okay people love to be
critics right about movies right now you
go into rotten tomatoes you go on imdb
all sorts of self-acclaimed critics
right yeah
and you know most of the time i'm okay
with opposite opinions because i've you
know i always want to know like what the
opposite opinion is right it's like okay
if i really enjoyed something right then
i want to see like how bad it is like if
i really hated something i want to know
you know why people might have enjoyed
it right i'm usually open to it i think
this might be the first time in my life
where
i don't understand the opposite opinion
because i saw so many people on like
twitter and like rotten tomatoes like
raiding dune is like oh it was [ __ ] it
was a disappointment and i'm like did
you watch the same movie that i watched
because it was genuinely the first time
where i'm like i actually don't
understand your criticism
like because is that why are you brain
dead yeah why it's like were you asleep
during the movie like so what about it's
so good then because i i'm gonna watch
it oh yeah i'm watching like every other
movie except that movie so like for one
it's like one of the uh so i'm like a
massive fan of the books yeah okay i
haven't read the book okay but that's
all right i still enjoy it yes
absolutely so i went with a couple of my
friends uh one of them has read the
books and the other two hadn't read the
book right so it was good to find out if
you needed to be a fan of the books or
not luckily everyone enjoyed it yeah but
i think it's because the movie did a
really good job of like picking and
choosing like the right information to
leave in the movie okay because there's
a lot of information in from the books
that they didn't include in movies
naturally i mean that's just how that's
just how book adaptations i mean dune is
like especially dune is like so [ __ ]
extensive when it comes to its law like
literally the first book at the back of
the book there's a little glossary of
terms that you need to understand to
read the book
like that's how it's just like its own
terms it's made up which is just terms
like frank herbert who was the creator
was like so like he was so five head
with this [ __ ] because like you know you
also have to understand this was written
in like 1965. like it's a 50 year old
sci-fi book is that old it's really old
yeah i i've heard it's like visually and
and the
sound is amazing oh yeah like
i'm gonna
this might be a hot take but i think it
is one of hans zimmer's best soundtracks
that is that is some fine words because
he's he's had some amazing sounds like i
thought
yeah
the boom the boom
like lion king soundtrack epic inception
he did like lion king he did lanky what
did you know he did lanky no no yeah how
does he did like what it was
i don't remember the soundtrack as in
like the battery
i remember i remember john
he's just going ham he didn't go
hamilton he was just going out to be
fair yeah yeah but he did you know he
did lion king he did inception he
obviously basically every christopher
nolan movie he did yeah and uh and i
thought he peaked at like interstellar
right like that's like the one
soundtrack everyone says it's like yeah
[ __ ] amazing movies so what did you
what would you give the movie out of 10
if i dress oh
your score because archaic system
judging movies yeah
sure uh i'd give it like a strong nine
oh wow yeah well i'm just gonna watch it
yeah i was i was gonna watch it because
the biggest criticism i've heard if you
can even call it a criticism really is
that so much of it depends on part two
because i've heard it's just it's not a
full movie it's just it covers the first
half of the first book yeah and it's a
two and a half hour movie yeah well when
they really stand too they'll probably
do the whole you can watch the first
movie before the second one you know
like a bundle packaging with the
avengers yeah yeah yeah you can watch uh
uh infinity war before end game yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah what i've heard about part one of
dune is that it's not like say you know
avengers of infinity war or like a lot
of people trying to build a whole world
yeah yeah where where you don't get like
a natural story arc it's just you get
half a star yeah i thought it's abrupt
yeah yeah yeah yeah it does kind of just
end with that piss people off yeah yeah
and i think as well the other big thing
is that i feel a lot of the criticism i
saw is that i think they kind of almost
gave it a little bit of false
advertising with like the trailer
because i watched the trailer of it and
there's like you know it looks like an
action sci-fi yeah the thing is dune is
not an action sci-fi it's a political
cycle yeah it's one of the things where
it's tough though you can't you can't
market politics yeah yeah which is like
just like your fans are crying
are you sure you can work
you can market politics but in a movie
it's kind of hard to be like and then he
signed the paper
yeah yeah
i mean that's just like that's just like
a lot of mecha and mate in a nutshell
people are just like oh giant robots got
a pee pew pew and then they're like wait
a minute i'm already invested in these
colonies and the politics of these
colonies what is all this government
[ __ ] what is what's going on you
don't tell someone game of thrones is
like a political thriller of
backstabbing and stuff like it's got
dragons and zombies yeah yeah yeah and
then like
yeah because i watched the trailer and
literally the entire trailer is
it's like 80 percent of it is a lot of
like fighting scenes yeah but what's
funny is that like
all of like all the fighting scenes in
the trailer are all the fighting scenes
in the movie oh okay oh okay all right
okay okay and so i'm not gonna watch the
trailer now because there's spoilers
no so i can see why like i think people
might have been maybe like misinformed
about it if they've never like read the
books or anything yeah maybe i don't
know since living in japan i've i've
been doing this thing where i just don't
look at reviews before and after the
movie yeah full stop i just do not look
at reviews anymore i just look at the
movie i watch a trailer i'm like it
looks okay yeah or if sometimes i don't
even watch the trailer i just pick one
yeah i just go to the cinema and i watch
it right around i've been really
enjoying movies a lot
i think that's the right thing yeah
that's the right thing it's hard because
sometimes i watch a movie and i'm like
i think that was good
but i need someone else to also tell me
because that's the days we live in yeah
because i experienced that recently with
uh i'm sure i don't think we can spoil
it but we were asked to watch something
by a company yeah right
uh and it was the first time you have to
make that so obvious
okay but it was the first time that uh i
had watched something i got like given
early access to something so even if i
wanted to there is no way i could check
whether this what i was watching was
good or not i
another episode but it was like such a
weird experience for me to be like
huh i i think this is good i like that
my opinion i think is right but
uh it it could be wrong it doesn't suck
that at the end of the day it just boils
down to i liked it what is it really me
yeah i think that i've started to like
from doing this a lot i've just because
now i don't treat movies as like i want
to watch that one film that's good it's
like i want to just do something for
three hours that like lets me shut off
yeah so i just go to movies watch
anything literally anything yeah um my
my problem with movies right now is that
i have such a short attention span like
like
like one place i can like shut off
like because i need i want to shut off
in the movie but i need to know that
it's worth my time right right that's
that's like it's like taking a leap of
faith and the thing is if you take that
leap of faith and that movie ends up
being good then you enjoy it way way
more but
i just i just have like i don't have the
attention span to sit through enough
shitty movies that i'm just like okay
i'm just not in the mood for this yeah
i'm not sure what's changed i don't know
why i'm like
because i'll tell you what i've been
doing actually to to offset this which i
know you think i'm a psychopath okay
which is whenever i get recommended
random clips on youtube for a movie i
haven't watched i see that clip and
sometimes it's like a banger clip and
i'm just like all right this movie is
worth watching i'm gonna watch in time
so you have to basically watch like a
portion of the movie before you're like
the whole thing there needs to be
something to sell me on this movie it
doesn't even need to be like a high
scoring movie or something that people
like everyone recommends there just
needs to be
something
about this movie that i'm just like okay
is there no part of you that just wants
to turn up to a movie and know nothing
about it and just watch something oh
yeah i mean that i think that's the
issue of
watching things for a job yeah you know
what i mean well i watch enough things
for a job blind anyway that we're in my
free time in my downtime i want to know
that this [ __ ]
because if it's not then it's just
another job
i understand that
it's weird because even if the movie
isn't as good as i would like it to be i
still get the same level of enjoyment
from just being in the environment
getting to experience watching something
even if it's [ __ ] i'm like i think you
just like the cinema experience i really
do and also i just like having it
sometimes it's nice
it's nice watching something yeah that's
bad so i can i can have a frame of
reference
right i can be like yeah
this is the thing everything i watch is
good i have no idea what's bad anymore
and this is why i think i relied on
reviews because i only ever watched
things that were good yeah and i feel
like the more i've just been watching
stuff and making my own opinions the
more i'm kind of enjoying the process of
then just being like
okay what do i think about that movie
not look at anything else yeah yeah it's
weird i don't know because i definitely
did feel that i'm i was so spoiled
watching everything that was quote
unquote good that was getting to the
point where i'm like all right i said
this must be i don't know this must be a
weird take i'm just like what is good
anymore i don't know
i mean i i watch enough [ __ ] things for
my job
for me like there's nothing that grinds
my gears more when i watch something and
i feel like it was just a waste of time
like something that's not entirely good
but not even that bad
yeah the mediocre ones are the ones the
mediocre ones are just like i could have
done so many things in that time which
is why you would never go out your way
to watch a five or a six out of ten no
no no but if you turn up in the cinema
you don't know what it is and you watch
five or six out of ten you're like no
okay but i'm not the kind of person who
just rocks up to a cinema and goes i'm
just gonna watch something yeah like if
i'm at a cinema i'm there for a specific
movie if like something for me to go to
a cinema i am committed to whatever i'm
watching
like
movie theater for you americans out
there
i don't [ __ ] use like because like to
me yeah i get it because if you're in
the movie theater are like you're just
you're committed to be there and i've
only ever walked out of one movie in my
life
and uh that was the live action ghost in
the show oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah and
that was just because i was just like i
watched about 40 minutes and i'm just
like this is neither good nor bad it's a
waste of my [ __ ] time right and i i
like i i went there by myself as well so
i'm like no commitments i am just going
to walk outs you know i think what
movies i watched um
i watched the last duel recently do you
remember the movie the [ __ ] was that all
right exactly right so so all the recent
movies yeah all i know about this movie
is that it starred adam driver and matt
damon okay that's all i knew about this
movie i knew that it was kind of based
in like the 1300s or something right
so turns out the plot is about something
uh where there was a
famous rape case in the 1300s in france
and it was kind of like unheard of that
there would be you know a court trial
around something like this yeah and then
it ended up in a duel and uh the whole
the whole movie of this thing is like
telling the perspective of each person
involved in in the in the rape right so
it's like the the woman's perspective
the guy doing the rape and then the
husband of the woman right right getting
raped and because obviously it's like
the 1300s so the rules are all like
totally [ __ ] and obviously yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and it was it was
it was good but it was also like really
weird because it was supposed to be like
1300s france and just matt damon was
there and like an american and then not
even
is this a new movie yeah but and then
like ben affleck was there are they
doing like a french accent no no it's
just american but it was just kind of
like okay
it was the first time in my life what
i'd ever genuinely felt like a movie was
bogged down by having actors i knew like
i was like this is just like
i just i don't need to see matt david
because he can't unsee matt damon
i'm watching this movie and i'm like
there could have been so many better
people who could have done this role
yeah and also
you know
if it was in french i wouldn't have
cared obviously it wouldn't have got the
budget and obviously you know that kind
of stuff yeah yeah but like i don't know
it felt weird because then there was
like american and then super british
dudes and then some dudes with french
accents and it was like this whole weird
thing where i was like
like i i think the movie was good but
also there was just like the casting
felt really weird yeah i didn't really
know what to think and then i did go
online and it was like eight point five
or something and i was like i was like
okay i mean i guess that makes sense but
yeah
do your opinions get skewed when you see
online reviews and or like when you have
your initial opinion and then you see
the reviews and then you would just
do you think your like opinion gets
skewered a bit um sometimes sometimes
i'd love to tell you i'm immune to my
yeah
everyone everyone out there watching is
just like
other people's opinion do not affect me
yeah i have my opinion and that's that
and i'm just like i think for most
things it doesn't affect me but then
there are times again where like similar
to your situation where it's like i'm
not sure if i enjoyed it or not so i
need like a second appearance
back me up this is a good film right
there's a good feel right you know and
the film is very uncomfortable and
you know it's kind of hard to watch at
times but then i'm also like i guess
that's the point though that's the idea
it's not supposed to be fun to watch
but then i'm going to the movies to pay
for watch something and so this i was in
this weird spot where i was like this
could be a four or an eight and i don't
know which one it is yeah by like public
and so it's one of those kind of one of
those movies i left it thinking like
okay i think it was an eight but i just
wish the casting was better i didn't
read anyone else's reviews i just saw
the score yeah i i don't know maybe
people disagree with me on that but i
was like yeah i was like whatever and
then on the opposite end of the spectrum
i was like i'm gonna watch james bond